And finally, to complete our shot,
we need to create a Cinema Camera.
This is the view in which the player will
see this whole sequence unfold.
So if we jump back to our sequence right now,
essentially all we have is just the character's movement.
In fact, the camera that we're viewing through
is essentially just the perspective camera
within Unreal.
So if we were to play the sequence back,
say at runtime or in a game,
there's really nothing that's going to control
the player seeing this.
So to do that, we need to add a Cinema Camera.
So we could go to Track,
and we could add an Actor to Sequence
if we had the Cinema Camera in our world,
or we could also add a Camera Cut Track.
But in this case, all I'm going to do
is go up to our Place Actors,
so underneath Windows, Place Actors,
and I'm going to search for Cinema,
and I'm going to drag this Cinema Camera Actor
into our sequence.
Now, before I let go and drag this in there,
I want you to notice that the only thing
we have in our sequence right now
is the SKM Bot.
So as soon as I drag this in there,
there we go,
you'll see that it not only adds the Cinema Camera,
so I'll roll these up,
so we have our Cinema Camera Actor,
and now we have a Camera Cut Track.
So if you recall at the beginning of this series
when we were having this class,
you'll notice that when I open up the sequence
and I click this little Play button,
you see that I actually viewed through the camera,
which is essentially what we're doing.
So I'm going to close my Place Actors tab,
and you'll notice that the camera itself
is off on the end here,
so I'm actually going to stop piloting this
and move this around,
and we'll go back to our shot here,
and one other thing as a pro tip to keep in mind
is by default, so if I'm in my viewport here,
and I click the little hamburger stack here,
the three patties,
you'll notice that Allow Cinematic Control is on by default.
If you turn this off,
it's going to stop whenever you open up a sequence
or you open up a camera,
it's going to stop the editor
from automatically selecting or controlling that viewport,
which is what we want,
because I want this just to be my perspective,
I want my right side to be my actual shot.
All right, so now if I select my Camera Cuts Track
and you'll see my Cinema Camera Actor,
I can click this little plus,
and now we see the camera,
which in this case is at zero, zero, zero,
which is under the world.
Not what we want.
So here's another little tip.
So if you notice a little camera icon
that says Unlock Viewport Camera Cut.
So if I unclick this,
so I'm no longer viewing,
but if I go down to my Cinema Camera Actor,
and this time I click the little camera icon next to it,
you'll see that I'm actually piloting
the Cinema Camera Actor.
In fact, I can do the same thing.
So if I eject out of here,
I could go perspective,
select my Cinema Camera Actor,
or go over into my world, right click,
and I should be able to pilot this,
which is not there in the right click,
but that's totally fine.
We'll just do it through here because truth be told,
when you're working with sequences,
most of the time you are in this interface.
So selecting back and forth between this
is a lot faster than navigating your outliner
or the viewport.
All right.
So with our Cinema Camera Actor selected,
and the camera itself locked to the viewport,
now I'm piloting this so I can move our camera up
just like we would with anything else.
And let's find our little platform,
which is over here.
There's our little character.
So now let's get our camera
roughly into position where we want it.
Perfect.
So we'll do something like this, like an overhead shot.
Now at this juncture,
not going into depth or details
about establishing cameras or using different zoom lengths
to establish different moods.
But in this case, we can just keep the default
or why not?
Feel free to go ahead.
You can change your film back,
maybe your lens settings and your zoom.
That's absolutely fine.
All right.
So now with our Camera Actor there,
I'm gonna go ahead and move my playback head here.
Let's go back to the beginning.
So here's our Camera Actor expanded out.
I'll go ahead and save our sequence that we have right now
and with my Camera Actor,
I'm going to expand out the transform.
So again, let's get this roughly into position
where we want it.
My transform, click our little plus key button right here.
We'll move to where the character jumps off.
So maybe what I wanna do
is just have the camera come to a rest.
So now I'm just gonna pilot it, move it forward.
And you'll notice as soon as I stop moving,
because we have auto key turned on, I get my key frames.
All right.
So let's just see how that looks.
Let's go back to the beginning and let's play.
You follow the character and he jumps off.
Great, fairly good movement.
Another little pro tip here
that when you have your viewport set,
so if I actually go up to perspective here,
cinematic viewport, as opposed to default,
I will have my playback control.
So these are your exact same playback controls
as my sequencer.
And I can scrub through, I can play, I can go back,
which is extremely handy.
But I also have some other tools here for like a grid.
So for example, if I turn on my grid shot here,
just so I can see my three by three grid,
and I follow my character for rules of composition,
maybe I don't like how this end shot ends
because he's kind of getting closer
to the left side of the frame.
Again, purely just an aesthetic choice.
But I could easily change that by doing this little trick.
So I'm going to select my transform keys.
I'm gonna go to my animation curve editor.
And what I'm gonna do here,
let me kind of move this off screen.
We'll reselect it here in a second,
just so we can see our character.
There we go.
So select my transform, you'll see it activates the keys.
And what I'm looking for, if we look at our axes here,
is Z is gonna be our up direction.
So maybe I wanna take my rotation of my,
which should be my yaw here.
And what I wanna do is actually just rotate this slightly.
So what I'm doing is grabbing this key,
which I'm gonna do this real quick,
and I'm holding down shift and middle mouse dragging.
And what that allows me to do is move the keyframe
and keep it snapped on the actual frame itself, so 135.
The other thing you could do is select it and drag,
but you'll see that it starts to move any way free form.
So again, either way that you wanna do it,
I'm gonna left click, drag, select the key,
and I'm gonna shift and middle click, drag,
just to keep him in that third.
Go ahead and save this.
And now we'll go back to our playback.
We'll see that the player starts to run and then he jumps.
So just a little bit better movement.
Again, purely an aesthetic choice.
You can do whatever you would like with it.
But now we have our camera cut.
We have our cinema camera actor, which is great.
We have our movement of our character.
We can save this.
In fact, to validate,
we can close the sequence to make sure everything works.
I can go back to my sequence tab, open my 105 EX,
and you'll see here we have it.
Now, again, if we start playing back,
you'll notice we just have a camera,
which is not what we want in the composition.
So go back to our sequence on our camera cuts track,
click this, which is going to lock this to our viewport.
And now when we play, we'll see the character runs.
He jumps and he falls.
Great, perfect.
Now, one other tweak that I wanna make is
it might not be readily visible through the video,
but you'll notice that the character is slightly blurry.
And that's because our focus range of our camera
is actually set a little far.
So we can actually control that down here very easily.
So you can see that there are a few settings
with our camera, and this is a great point
to kind of explain that in Sequencer,
we have a lot of control that we can take.
In fact, there are a lot of properties and parameters
that can be keyed, can be controlled, et cetera,
but you may only see a few of them
inside of the sequence when it's active.
So what I'm gonna do is actually select
my cinema camera actor, which essentially
just selects it in my outliner, go to my details panel.
And one of the first things to look at is
anytime you see this little kind of triangle
or rotated square, however you wanna do it
with a plus button, that just means
that simply add a key frame for that property.
So in this case, what I wanna actually change
is my focus distance.
We're gonna focus settings, you'll see here,
manual focus distance is what is set
and is currently at a thousand centimeters.
So if we turn on our draw debug focus plane,
you'll see that it's way off in the distance.
I can use my little eyedropper, so just left click once,
go in and then pro tip here, middle mouse click
will actually select it or you can left click,
which should move it.
All right, so about roughly 977 centimeters
away from the camera is my character.
So now if I turn off my draw debug focus plane,
you see he's much more in focus,
a lot more crisp, which is what we want.
Now, if we found, because I've set this
on the actual camera itself, but I haven't key framed it,
it just sets it as its value.
So if I scrub through and let's say at this juncture,
he does get a little blurry.
In fact, let's do our draw debug focus plane.
Maybe he's a little outside of that, it doesn't look good.
We could add a key frame, so if I do this real quick,
you'll see that it creates a key
on this manual focus distance and we could modify that.
So I could grab this key, move it back real quick
to the beginning, we have to hold down shift and snap,
drag to the end here.
And maybe I just want to move this out slightly.
There we go, I have my second key.
And now you'll see that that focus stays relatively
within the position of where our character's at.
The other thing to keep in mind here too,
is as we established our camera,
we don't necessarily want this camera
to exist in the world, at least for this example.
Now you could if you wanted to,
but we want it to be a spawnable actor.
And if you notice that we didn't actually have
to right click on this and create a spawnable,
because the editor did it for us automatically.
And that is because if you recall,
we dragged the cinema camera actor
from our place actors tab into the sequence itself.
So the sequencer naturally assume
that that's going to be a spawnable actor
because you're putting it within the sequence.
Now we could go back to here
and just convert it to a regular, just a possessable,
but we're going to leave it as is.
So if you dropped your camera in the level
and you don't have the little lightning bolt,
just right click on it and convert it to a spawnable.
Perfect.
So you can see here too, again,
we've taken our cinema camera actor,
we added our first key frame for the transform,
and then we moved our play head
and then move the camera slightly.
Again, I would encourage you to play with this, right?
Maybe the camera's lower,
maybe it's more overhead looking down.
Whatever you want to create, feel free to.
Feel free to innovate, try different things,
make the camera give a different feeling to the sequence.
Absolutely fine.
And then finally, the next thing that we're going to do
is essentially build out these exact same shots
for our second and our third shot.
So we're not going to do that,
but what I'm going to do in the next video
is highlight how shot two is slightly different
and how shot three is slightly different
than the rest of them
and how we were able to achieve those same results.
If you want to follow along with this next part,
you can easily just go back to the world that we have
and you could go to courses and then the sequence 905.
And then in this sequence,
let me clear my filter out here.
We have our M-S-E-Q 905 final.
You could double click this
and you'll see all of the structure that we have.
All right, so in the previous video,
we actually established our first shot,
which if I kind of go to my timeline here
is exactly this.
So I'm going to activate my camera cuts track,
which will put the active camera in my viewport.
I'm going to middle click real fast
and just press G to go into game mode,
just so it hides all of the little UI features.
So if I go back to the beginning and we press play,
you'll see there's kind of our first shot
that we established.
Now again, slightly different
based off of the previous video,
but for demonstration purposes,
you'll see it's the same thing, right?
We have our main character that we have here
and we've animated the character.
So kind of zoom in here.
So we have our run.
We have our jump and then we have our fall.
Now, if you're curious about these little blends,
all you really need to do is if you have an animation,
so this little track here
and you drag it backwards over another animation.
Now, in case this is locked here,
it'll actually create a blend between the two.
That way it actually interpolates the animation.
So where the rig is moving
to give you smoother blended results.
And of course you can drag these key frames to control it.
Great feature.
But again, for the purposes of this class,
we've got our run,
go to here, we've got our jump
and then we have our fall animation
and we've animated the transform of that character.
We also have our camera.
Now I've renamed mine to CCA underscore O one,
which is that first camera.
And you see again, we have our camera component
and then our transform
and all we're simply doing is just changing the location
of it to give us kind of a nice dollying crane shot
for this particular scene, which is very simple.
All right.
So if you understand those core fundamentals,
really the subsequent shots here after,
so our second shot,
which is the character running up to the platform.
And then finally our third one,
which is the character standing here
and then eventually jumping and running off.
We've essentially replicated the exact same things.
So I highly encourage you to go create these shots again.
This is gonna be in our sequence 905.
If you open up this level sequence,
you'll have everything assembled,
but essentially you're just building out
a little visual storytelling narrative.
So in this case, the bot jumps
and now he's running to go talk to the player,
which we'll find out in the advanced class after this,
that we actually have a trigger volume.
So this is where the sequence occurs
cause the player hits the platform.
Hence why our little pink guy here
is actually running to that platform.
All right.
So if we take a look just at our second shot,
you'll see we have this CCA O two camera,
which we'll come back to.
And then if we click our little bot friend,
you'll see, we now have a new bot, which is spawnable.
And you'll see that all we've really done
is we've added this animation here.
So here's our run animation.
So we'll run up to the platform.
And then as soon as he hits the top,
we go to this a bot idle,
which is him just standing there.
In fact, we can use our secondary view port.
Just kind of zoom in here.
So we have the idle
and then we'll eventually trigger to our third shot.
Okay.
So very, very basic.
All we're doing is animating this bot,
adding the animations and then using our transform.
So you can see all the keys here
that are required for this.
Now, if you'll notice,
there's some interesting things happening
in the middle here.
So we have, again, if you recall, right click,
our different key interpolations,
which is just how the movement coming into the key
and the movement exiting the key, how those change.
And the reason why we're using kind of a mix
of these linears and these auto curves.
And then we also have a cubic auto is for this reason.
So as the shot was being built,
there were some issues with the character phasing
through this particular platform.
So if you notice that our Z direction,
which is right here, location,
we have it set to linear.
So he goes up the ramp, but even in here,
so we'll kind of zoom in a little bit just to show,
there was just some weirdness happening,
trying to get the animation to line up
and not make the character look like he's phasing through.
We do have some of that.
But again, this is principles and these are issues
that have plagued animation since the dawn of animation,
whatever it was, that you may be fighting
some of the world, hence why you would wanna go in there
and maybe add some different keys,
use your graph editor here as well to fine tune these
and tweak it to get the right position.
But for the purposes of this demonstration,
you'll notice that the actual final camera
is kind of far away from the character.
So this was good enough.
Does that have to be perfect?
Well, that's your call or whoever's making the calls
if they want it to be perfect,
but in this case, this was good enough.
All right, so again, we have our main bot.
We've animated it, so his position,
and we haven't run up the ramp.
And if you notice, the other thing we have here
with our camera is that he stays perfectly fixed
right in the middle.
So if I play this back,
you see perfectly in the center of the camera.
So on top of the other principles
that we've talked about with our camera,
just creating it, setting our lens,
setting our focus as well.
One of the other properties
that we're able to change in the camera
is this focus method.
So by default, we're actually using manual,
which allows us to specify the distance.
Now, I have changed that in the secondary shot
from manual to tracking.
And from there, if I expand out the tracking focus,
you'll see that I can track an actor.
So in this case, I'm using the SKM bot B,
which is this guy, so SKM bot B.
And we're able just to track him,
and that's all we have to do.
So switch from manual to tracking,
and then we're gonna change the actor to track
to our SKM bot B, or click the little eyedropper,
and then click on the character itself,
and it will activate that actor.
And that's all we need to do.
The camera will do the rest of the work.
Now, you could, if you wanted to, at this juncture.
So even though the camera is looking at the actor,
you still could animate the transforms.
So let's say that we wanted to have this camera
be like a tracking shot along a rail.
And so maybe we add, so let me click our camera here.
We'll fly up into here.
So there's our camera looking at our guy, right?
We could go in here and we could move it.
We could do whatever we need to.
In fact, you can see there's a little bit
of subtle movement from vertical to,
or at least in the vertical axis, moving up and down.
So you see that you can still animate
over the top of the camera itself,
even though we are set to track the actor.
All right, perfect.
And then if we move on to our shot three,
this is probably the most basic shot.
So I'm gonna roll up my CCA camera two,
because now we're using CCA camera three.
So I'm not really doing anything necessarily.
In fact, there's really no movement.
I've simply just added some key frames to lock it.
But if we go to our graph editor,
you'll see that they're just flat keys.
So the camera doesn't really move.
And the reason for that is in our final shot,
this is actually the point.
So here on our action event,
this is where the player has to give some kind of command.
So the general thought here is that our little NPC here
is saying, hey, welcome, it's so good to see you.
I have a quest for you.
Do you want to accept yes or no, or whatever it is.
And then the player does a key
and then he says yippee and runs off.
So again, our camera is just gonna stay fixed here.
We don't really want any movement.
And then the bot itself.
So in this case, we're repurposing our SKM bot.
Yes, we absolutely can do that.
You'll see that once he gets up to the platform,
he just stays in position.
In fact, if I have him selected, I'll press F here,
kind of zoom around here.
So you see that he runs up
and then we put him in an idle position
and he stays there until our action event.
And then he does a little jump,
which if we zoom in here,
see here's that jump to a run, just like that.
And of course they are blended together
by simply just dragging the animation
over the top of the other
and we'll get our blend in between.
And then of course, at some point,
we need to transform him to what their animations.
So here's that motion up.
We hold, here are our key frames right here.
So as he holds and then he jumps,
we do a little bit of forward movement,
little bit of rotation, and then he runs off screen.
And that's it.
So building out these three particular shots
is fairly straightforward and fairly easy.
Even though it may look like a complicated process here
with the final assembly,
really all we're doing is just putting our camera,
animating the movement of our camera,
adding some animations to our character,
and then just making sure that their translation,
rotation, values are really not scaling,
but just making sure that those values
make the animations feel natural.
And that's really it.
One of the other key things that we've added here
just to highlight real quick
is inside of our third shot.
So if you notice there are two lights on this character.
In fact, if I select both of them
and then just turn them off and on,
you'll see essentially all we're doing
is just helping to separate our NPC character
from the background.
So if these were off,
you see that the background draws more of your attention.
So by using the exact same principles of spawnables,
essentially what we've done
is in our dialogue key and dialogue rim.
So again, respectively, if I turn these on and off,
so I'll take my dialogue key.
See here, this is just that key light.
I'll turn it off.
And then our rim light here,
you see just kind of add some separation
from the background.
The two of these in our scene,
you'll see right at this point right here.
So 360 when our cameras change from this one to this one
is when both of these will spawn.
In fact, we can see that by these two key frames here.
So you can actually key frame spawn on or off,
which is a great principle that,
say for example,
there's another shot that comes after this.
Then we come back here.
You may want to spawn the dialogue
and the dialogue rim key,
or I'm sorry, the dialogue key and the dialogue rim lights,
spawn them, turn them off, turn them on.
You can actually key those, which is great.
Perfect.
And that essentially is the creation
of our shot one, two, and three.
So feel free if you want to,
to go through this process
and rebuild it exactly as it is, or change it up,
give a different narrative to your sequence.
Absolutely fine.
But essentially we're building these shot one, two, and three
and again, if you want to just kind of skip ahead,
not a problem.
Sequence 905 in the sequence,
just open up this MSEQ 90500 final,
which will have everything assembled
and ready for you to go
in case you want to reverse engineer that.